this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
okay so let's talk a little bit more
about primary structure which of course
refers to the order or specific sequence
of amino acids linked in a polypeptide
chain okay when you have primary
structure that that order that sequence
of amino acids is read from left to
right from n to C which means from the
amino terminus to the carboxy terminus
that is how you read the actual order
okay in in order and it's held together
by peptide bonds okay
peptide bonds whoops peptide bonds which
are covalent amide linkages they hold
together primary structure okay and so
what does that look like over here
because I've drawn a little peptide over
to the right here so the backbone of
this polypeptide chain is NCC cuz NCC
backbone so here's the starting off at
this N and then we got the alpha carbon
right at C and the carbonyl carbon see
that's one amino acid okay then I have
another and see see that's another amino
acid and CC sometime in another amino
acid and I have n CC so have another
amino acid there and we've got those
different R groups
now I haven't indicated specifically
those R groups being different but the
order in which this this peptide would
be red would be from n to C so left to
right this way okay this is the amino
terminus here and this is the carboxy
terminus here okay and to see now each
of those R groups would define what
amino acid that is so here this would be
the R group for amino acid number one
this would be R group number two or
three number four and that this way here
we have four amino acids linked together
by peptide bonds which are amide
linkages and it amide just looks like
this name ID is uh some carbonyl next to
a nitrogen like that okay
and so the peptide bonds are between
each amino acid so I went through and
marked NCC for all of them so I the
first NCC
and then I have a bond to the next one
so this bond right here is the peptide
bond between this amino acid and the
next one okay and then I have NC C and
then I have this bond that's the am ID
bond the peptide bond then I have NC C
and then I have this peptide bond and of
NC C and then there's no next amino acid
over here so there's there's just those
three peptide bonds holding the four
amino acids together okay and so so if I
were to go through and read the order of
this I would just mention this amino
acid first whatever based on its R group
and then this one right in here and then
this one so this would be amino acid
number one amino acid number two amino
acid number three and amino acid number
four and that would be actual order the
actual primary structure okay so let's
let's actually use an example so this is
actually pretty something pretty
important so two peptides that we're
going to show here that have the same
amino acid content but different amino
acid sequences which is important so
they have the same amino acids they're
just linked in a different order at
different sequences okay so let's check
them out so peptide 1q h g l fa so q
glutamine h histidine g glycine
l-leucine f phenylalanine a alanine and
so over to the left this would be the
amino acid that is on the amino terminus
and then over here to the right we have
alanine the carboxy terminal amino acid
and over here peptide two we have the
same amino acids just in a different
order h fa q LG as opposed to qh g l fa
so here this is the amino terminal amino
acid and then over here we have the
carboxy terminal amino acid it's the
glycine so they're the same amino acid
content but different amino acid
sequences and therefore they would
actually have different structures
because I don't know if I mentioned this
or I haven't written down of course but
I don't think I explicitly mentioned it
the primary structure is what determines
the overall 3d structure the protein the
actual order of the amino acids will
place a gigantic role in determining how
that protein or the how that probably
peptide will fold into a protein and
obviously this is a simple example with
six amino acids here but you could apply
the same same concept to much larger
polypeptides okay so so yeah so you can
have actually the same amino acid
content but different amino acid
sequences and you get entirely different
proteins
okay cool so just as an important note
or a noteworthy note mutations of course
mutations that result in the changes the
primary structure can alter the overall
3d shape and thus the function of a
protein so an example is sickle-cell
disease there's a missense mutation
specifically in the beta globin gene of
hemoglobin okay and so we get the
hemoglobin protein ends up being
different and of course mutations in the
DNA can alter a protein structure and so
sickle-cell disease are a missense
mutation in the beta globin gene has a
significant impact and so normally that
globin gene it's normal primary
structure has it looks it's this is not
this is of course not its entire
structure but there's a prolene and two
glutamates but in the sickle cell
primary structure we have a prolene of
valine and a glutamate so the difference
between these two is that in the normal
one we have a glutamate and in the
sickle-cell the only difference is that
this one has a faylene okay so that's a
one amino acid different okay and as far
as their side chains probably inside
changes neutral glutamate sidechain is
acidic so it's negatively charged
whereas in this in this one over here
prolene also so neutral valine is
neutral not negatively charged and
glutamate over here is negatively
charged so there's a difference there
and that difference I'm not going to
talk about all kinds of crazy
details right now but that is that is
important because that just that one
amino acid change results in a gigantic
difference in terms of what the cells
look like in normal individuals that are
that don't have the disease and
individuals who do have sickle cell
disease so normally people have red
blood cells that look like this and
they're like little circles that have
these little dimples in them okay
whereas individuals with sickle cell
disease have sickle shaped red blood
cells that look kind of like moons like
this and there are a lot of different
detriments as far as far as their health
so the whole idea though is that just a
single amino acid change in a certain
protein that hemoglobin protein in red
blood cells has a drastic impact on the
structure of that hemoglobin and as an
extension of these red blood cells so so
yeah so primary structure is incredibly
important to understand yeah and I think
that's it
so I hope that video was helpful thank
you for watching